una firme Promesa de acabar con la
corrupción en Guatemala
Bernardo Arévalo dio una gran sorpresa
durante la primera vuelta de las
elecciones generales del 25 de junio su
nombre no figuraba entre los primeros en
las encuestas pero se ubicó en el
segundo puesto de las votaciones el
candidato de 64 años Fue diputado los
últimos cuatro años y ha criticado la
represión en contra de jueces Fiscales y
periodistas exiliados bueno las más
urgentes van a ser todo lo relacionado a
la lucha contra la corrupción porque sin
lucha contra la corrupción no vamos a
poder rescatar las instituciones que
necesitamos para generar el desarrollo
su inesperado éxito electoral refleja
que una de las principales
preocupaciones de los guatemaltecos es
la corrupción que azota al país nació en
Uruguay y vivió varios años en Francia
durante el exilio de su padre el
expresidente Juan José Arévalo Bermejo
quien gobernó entre 1945 y 1951 y fue el
primer mandatario democrático de
Guatemala tras décadas dictatoriales
Bernardo Arévalo tiene estudios en
filosofía y antropología
diplomático desde la década de los 80s
en 2015 inició su activismo en contra
del gobierno lo que lo llevó a
convertirse en fundador y diputado del
movimiento semilla este 2023 obtuvo un
poco más del 12% en la primera ronda de
votaciones ahora enfrentará a la ex
primera dama y abanderada del
conservadurismo Sandra Torres que
consiguió el 16%
porque es bien conocida Pero él ni nos
imaginábamos de que con él se iba a
segunda vuelta
ha prometido seguir los pasos de su
padre para mejorar la educación reducir
la violencia y la pobreza que afecta al
59% de los 17.6 millones de
guatemaltecos también ha dicho que no
legalizará el aborto libre ni el
matrimonio igualitario pero aseguró que
no permitirá la discriminación ni
estigmatización por género ni religión
ahora con su eslogan de regresar la
democracia a Guatemala intentará llegar
a la casa presidencial